hey everyone Avengers infinity war has
been in theaters for a week now and you
know what you've had time to see the
movie so look out we're gonna talk about
the ending guys
the shocking departures in this movie oh
boy are the characters whom we saw die
or fade away really dead
we're fated to wait can they come back
good things be like reset in some way if
so how would that work we'll get to
those questions but first welcome to new
rockstars news it's our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week and
it's Star Wars day guys it's May the
fourth we're also gonna talk about the
upcoming Han Solo movie yes it's still
happening Star Wars Episode nine rumors
and then we're gonna chat about the
swampthing streaming series and whether
or not the Infinity Gauntlet still works
I'm Erik Bosse joining me at this table
are over here Sam basher how's everyone
doing oh hey I'm Phillip Melina and I
brought a friend with me today DJ
Waldridge you might know him from Sam's
podcast but also DJ is producing a comic
book this and we're going to get into
that later but he's like indie
self-funding or ever and you guys should
definitely check it out I DJ knows
everything there is to know about comics
I'll put all my footage comic it
references everything and it's better
than every comment if you thought
Avengers was a big multi cross caster
comic about that but for now let's get
started with our top story
the shocking ending of Avengers infinity
war Thanos was successful in his mission
to snap half the universe out of
existence including half of the Marvel
heroes we know and love among them were
some heroes who will most likely get
their upcoming sequels of their own
spider-man's follow-up to homecoming
will start shooting in July and the
third guardians of the galaxy was given
a release date May 20 2003 at the movie
that's just not it's not confirmed
they'll be in those films right oh right
poor idle and cruelly little no Ned
really went all in with that and they
were like no all every Marvel movie from
here on out is a prequel when he went on
a vacation with his parents we get to
see how his parents died and with uncle
Uncle Ben and Aunt May yeah another one
of those seasons so question the real
question is how are they really dead if
they aren't dead where do they go and
how how could they come back now I
actually think it would be good to first
talk about the other characters that we
saw die throughout the movie prior to
Dan assist snaps reverses snap they're
remembered low-key got choked to death
Heimdall got impaled in the chest and
unlike pretty much every other character
that got impaled in the chest in the
movie have actually killed him got
thrown off a cliff so Thanos could get
the soulstone vision got his mine stone
ripped out of a circuitry and it turned
him into this lifeless great color and
of course all the members of the Black
Order die but who cares about sub
Dylan's guys I mean it might be a dumb
question but are these deaths permanent
is there any way that these characters
could be brought back these specific
ones these yeah though I feel bad saying
this the only one I feel super confident
we will probably not see again as
Heimdall I feel the one I feel confident
we will definitely see again is Gamora
mhm
she seems that even though Loki Bannos
even said like no more resurrections for
him whatever I even though he said that
I could still see him coming back and
there was just one if you're looking for
a little ray of hope later one Thor is
talking about him he says specifically
the word might yeah and this really
might be the last time conditional why
would you introduce the possibility that
it might not be if you're not you know
look it was the only time also because
since Loki died before this was the most
emotion we ever got out of Thor for him
dying so I feel like that and should be
assigned to us as the viewers I'm one
better directing but also that the that
this might actually mean more than my
time
to be where I'm not the one making the
movies no honestly I think also our pink
boy over there is not gonna do too great
but is evil I think I just play that
sucker right I don't have a soul they
put the soul stone
they put the soul stone in division good
more possessors vision body as an
Android Guardians 3 confirmed I think I
honestly as much as I like all these
characters I'd be bummed if any of them
did like I think its back if they did
come back yeah if I think we will see
some of the fader wares come back but if
we go all the way back and find ways to
bring these characters back like some
people have to die in order these things
to have steaks right no no no no I mean
a real question does vision have a
backup on a Wakanda servers question
programming him when he went so like
many of the ones that would go permanent
visions fine you can have vision yeah he
did his bit he was more important than I
ever expected him to be no I wanted more
I want more that pink boy I want him
flying around lazy through walls I'm not
really sure how his powers work on
whether or not they would come back from
kind of a character arc perspective did
they complete their arcs right I do
think vision is the most human you ever
see vision in this movie literally yeah
yeah we seem that way but then also I
mean that might be a hitting us over the
head with it yeah he also he cares more
about a human being and love than his
duties as a male sex pot and then Loki
is is probably the most redeemed yeah
that he's been he also refers himself as
Odin son which is something that I think
you know it completes kind of a little
bit of his arc in the four movies
specifically how he's not Odin son and
yet you know he says did you ever happen
in are you sure she he says he just let
him go let it lay ages up a bit or do
anything
yeah he got his paycheck he can do no
other thing yes so hair yeah
did she complete in art no that's the
one I Bryce may be open no yeah you got
at least she had so much like she
covered so much ground as a character in
this movie which I really appreciated
not just in her love life but also with
her father which I mean it was pivotal
for the movie I don't think that's an
that only that's enough that's not an
ending for her it was a cool moment for
her but I think she's probably I think
we all kind of agree that she's probably
the one that will come back first yeah
and then we'll get forced ghost I think
it wouldn't surprise me if in guardians
3 we see like Peter for some reason
remembers all the like big declarations
of love and she doesn't so now in
classic like so proper calm so it's like
oh well also in the comics Kimora has a
really big tie like in this movie with
the soulstone usually she it's just
weird
yeah I did a whole video on soulstone
and it still doesn't make it
understandable but uh it's that there's
a dimension which you saw in the movie
where it's like this pool reflecting
pool and it looks like it's a like a
piece of gamora's homeworld and you see
her as a baby that's the soul world
that's like a little pocket dimension
within the soul gem so usually in the
comics for some reason she and Adam
warlock decide to just go live in there
she can leave whenever she wants so I
think and they committed this is true
they can make it really hot it's like
the outside of the stone like so some of
the ow and it's actually super weird
part of the Infinity Gauntlet comic
they're already in there it just jumps
in with them leaving and so that's the
one part that the rest of you can kind
of just pick up that comic like get the
gist of it that's the one like what
because they believe or they die and
then they go into cocoons to become
their true selves like what's happening
like it's going on right now well it
brings up this interesting question of
mechanics right so how could any of
these resurrections or returns happen
and I think that kind of brings us to
the snap you know the other characters
we see fade away because I think it's
almost certain that some of them will
come back right so the characters we saw
a fade away into dust included Bucky
Black Panther Groot
Falcon Scarlet Witch mantis Drax Peter
quill Doctor Strange spider-man and then
in the post-credits scene Nick Fury and
Maria Hill as much as before these
characters can't all be gone forever a
lot of them have sequels in the pipeline
and the waste
these people either all went somewhere
where they aren't really dead or somehow
their departures will be like rewound or
reset and some new reality how do you
guys think this could work I think one
of the biggest themes from the movie
which we wanted to do like a like
there's a lot to unpack from this movie
but one of the big themes is what you're
willing to sacrifice to succeed and like
so forth a knows he's willing to do
anything and that's why he wins then
that everybody else like you get this
back and forth which I feel like you can
explain it better but between vision and
calories like no I'll sacrifice myself
is like no no we don't sacrifice one
he's like you did it yeah you did it and
World War two so it's like a I think the
way that this would basically we'd
probably get a rebound or like a reset
on the timeline maybe they'd add new
elements so it's like oh it's a new
adventure it's a new universe out there
that we get to explore in future movies
but I think we're gonna get characters
having to make that like big sacrifice
for it
like like a neo kind of thing which I
mean obviously is taken from the Bible
right there like the original story of
neo is kind of Jesus I don't know which
one came first the idea that neo dies
for our sins yeah and then you know I
kind of is resurrect whatever I could
see a version of however they fix it
maybe someone like cap has to like do
that thing where it's like wait someone
has to stay inside with the bomb the
classic knocked the guy out no it's me
not the guy anybody do that it would
probably be I think you're right but I
think it would probably be Tony
Tony's it feels like he's been building
towards a Redemption arc for him since
the jump but especially since Ultron in
the Civil War and everything yeah but I
think once you introduced the idea that
a magic snap can wipe out half people
then a magic snap can undo that thing
like it's not it's not the most the
light switch it's just a little I think
of snapping backwards is surprisingly
hard yeah also interesting element that
they introduced and it sounds like we're
probably gonna dive into more is in the
comic literally once you have any pin
Ogawa there's no limits you can just do
whatever you want in this movie it looks
like it takes a
an amount of energy to accomplish stuff
and it looks like the got the actual
mechanism of the gauntlet itself doesn't
doesn't do so well ha in the in the
snapping exerting that much energy which
is cool also a because every watch the
movie it looks like it's like fused to
his arm now it looks like that at the
end he is actually when I stones might
not be there but it looks like on the
rewatch I specifically was like and it
looks like there's something either even
on a gold glove after but there's
something gold still on it's either
either it's long his armors arms screwed
up from the thing because what I signed
and see gold I saw a chart messed up
this so ambiguous another reason to
watch it again yes for that one right
yeah and like what happened to the
garland we're gonna be talking about
that later this later this episode but
yeah I think that does bring up a good
question is like will the gauntlet and
the stones be the the way out of it or
the way they come back a world will be
some other kind of rules or some other
kind of entity from the Marvel world we
mentioned Chronos last week of great
other entities that can control time or
are these other kind of god-like deity
figures who can kind of change the rules
or reset things we've seen that in
sci-fi before that would be weird
instead of a MacGuffin chase again if
they were trying to find another more
ancient because it this this movie just
skipped right over I think probably to
its benefit all of a major Eternals any
other major cosmic and in the comics you
the universe has a personification and
it just jumps right over all that it's
but it'd be interesting if that was the
answer I know they also talked about
when everybody you know those set photos
of the been in the classic Avengers garb
and the directors were like maybe not
the time stone maybe that barf
technology from Civil War that makes you
relive your most traumatic memories or
what everyone's like okay I don't know
how that fixes any bad yeah and why they
have to have that thing on their hands
yeah
maybe Tony invented a time machine who
knows that would be pretty fun that
would be cool to see some of the bigger
cosmic characters it would I would love
just to hear the explanation for it
you're right because but it is also
slightly more approachable where like
you like oh no he can make a thing that
we can talk about you know though when
totally the other way probably make it
like they made ego celestial they were
probably instead of like delivering
personification the universe it's
another celestial that is function
similarly yeah I think it should be our
most handsome actor it's another way and
it would be almost presented with
dance-off to save the universe
he's like a sing-off to say the universe
such a good yeah such a great if if it's
not some other kind of entity and we
talked about like personal sacrifice I
think that's almost a given right like
not all these actors are gonna make it
through the end of Avengers 4 right a
lot of them seem done this kind of seems
like by resetting it back to the
original Oh the original og 6 from the
first Avengers seems like it might be at
least some of their last movie another
way I could see it going is like and I
keep I know a lot of you're annoyed that
I keep comparing this to the Harry
Potter movies but it is kind of similar
with Part one and Part two you're
chasing these MacGuffins and then and
I'll throw out the Harry Potter books in
book six you introduced this idea of the
Horcrux it's writing you gotta find the
Horcruxes and that's kind of the key to
the villains power and then book seven
they kind of blew our minds we're like
actually there's three more MacGuffins
that are kind of like the other side of
it and what if there's like another set
of Infinity stones or another set of
like MacGuffins that they have to chase
and part two that's somehow like
complete the opposite side of the puzzle
that can better be all of them that's
insane because a lot of they're big
they're big other MacGuffins they just
rolled into Infinity stones like in the
comics the tesseract is is a different
thing I know it is now it is
moto is something else yeah there's some
people at home they're like I don't know
what I MacGuffin is it's when you get a
McChicken and and then you chase it for
a whole movie at a kid has a lot of
power
yeah there might be too much but I don't
know it could be give him something else
to do it they did say that like the
title of Avengers 4 would be as spoilers
no but also we're like we didn't mean
like that big a deal we meant more like
if we say the title then you guys are
gonna be like who cares about Avengers 3
oh yeah where you're gonna be thinking
about Avengers also said you should be
scared by he should be yeah yeah Jason
Voorhees shows up he was an actor in
Thor Ragnarok and there's another person
the same universe well you know Jason
Bourne is not Jason Bourne my favorite
thing about the fourth movie is that
iron fist is finally gonna get the big
hero moment that we've all been waiting
for right he gets to put the Infinity
Gauntlet on iron fist and all snaps the
universe and we forget that I exist
there's your mcfist right yeah did you
uh did you see that the Russo brothers
were like we actually did consider
whether or not we should bring in those
characters no they said literally for
one minute I was a big proponent of it
until I saw the movie I'm like no of
course that you can't too many
characters in the post credits if it had
just been we take some visits in some
different places and we see some
important character oh man like what I
do let me so depraved would be like if
World War Z in that post-credits scene
was like every other place on the planet
that didn't get the cure yet it's like
let's watch these kids die
yeah his family dies but this is Romania
they included Nick Fury and Maria Hill
for that reason to make it even more
tragic there's a show like the ground
level of like no it's not just the
superheroes everything yeah I do
secretly hope
once they reach a pin these people show
up we still need to punch Santos one
last time right and they put out a call
I cap does one of his classic speeches
like litter I don't know who you are but
whatever so everybody shows up like that
it's literally just one of those splash
pages where like all the Avengers all
the defenders maybe we even further
Runaways in there they're all just
they're not one shot running at Thanos
why their 13 year old roll credits the
last shot yeah we should should also
remember that the snap wait effected
yeah they affected everyone not just the
characters on screen and I you know we
saw those like anonymous wakandan
soldiers and civilians so I'm curious
what this means for em suit characters
with the unknown fates like Clinton
Barton and his family and Scott Lang
hope Van Dyne Hank Pym Ned Leeds and MJ
Aunt May Pepper Potts happy Hogan Jane
Foster Valkyrie Korg meek Wong Cherie
Queen Ramon da'wah cobby Everett Ross
like if somebody wants to do a quick cut
of all the videos lately how many lists
Eric has done of names
I'm very impressed because you've
memorized yeah I'm gonna throw out there
really quick this is regarding future
mtv movies who might have been affected
by the Snapple yeah I'm gonna say
ant-man and the wasp post-credit scene
ant-man is hanging out with his daughter
as she fades away
oh I mean cuz the movie already looks
like a ton of fun that's a great way to
happen off of like you don't get to be
happy it has to connect for it to be
kind of work I know that before yeah I
don't think if it's just like it wasn't
this fun and then we all remember to be
sad by the way I think the best way they
could have put the defenders in there is
a quick like insert shot on the clearly
shot on a cell phone over there like a
test shoot of the daredevil costume he's
like mMmmm just cut back to Giant Hulk
alien thing like beating up a statue in
Central Park and you're like I'm just
gonna get in the way
one theory that I saw that looked really
interesting is the the reason Clint
comes back in the fold is his family
among the people who fade away and into
the road in the Asgardians leave it's
like wait
but you kill half of us and we wire will
include why are we more don't half
that's not fair yeah sorry interesting
if going back to a man thing if it was
maybe the way you could do that bit be a
little less painful is it hanging I want
her to scream as she goes Pym vanishes
and like Scott freaks out he calls his
wife like hey and then you stop like it
was my daughter still they're probably
not yeah but it's interesting because we
the post-credits scene for a man and
wasp probably deals directly with this
and then Katherine Marvel probably also
leads into her the other side of the
beeper like oh no I got beeped I got
paged hold on yeah the universe yeah
right she's way taking a nap yeah on the
free home world like what you've been up
to for yes
well day yeah I'm really fascinated to
see how that pager is going to like do a
block of ice squishing heads where was
she
yeah exactly just not been helpful no
they flat out said she's going to be the
most powerful character yeah it's like
essentially our universal rapture event
and I'm just kind of curious to see
which characters fade away that could be
a really fun thing that they deal with
like God the Pope yeah I heard stories
that they shot a lot of things with
supporting characters about of with them
fading and then they decided to not
include that just because like once you
see Black Panther and spider-man go
you're like what people get that I don't
know because I also love you cheered
during that part
I don't feel but I this was great for
you I like in in post-apocalyptic movies
or in disaster movies I love seeing how
humanity has to quickly recover so like
an Independence Day for instance like
the way that the you know the Congress
is destroyed in the white hole DC is
destroyed like or anything like
designated survivor where it falls all
the way down to the Secretary of
Education now becomes president
I love seeing those ramifications so I
think it'd be really interesting to kind
of see you know the world you're talking
about where it's like on the other side
of half of the population that I mean
sure the universe but specifically earth
because that's where I live like work
what what has to change now like like
you know there are they're survivors
remorse groups like yeah that world work
I don't think they'll get into it no but
I do like that like that when you get to
like dive into like the psychology of
like yeah like forth of the people on
the planet disappeared what do you do
now yeah been caps phone rings like cap
you're now president of the world yeah
there's also Secretary of Treasury
leftovers it was only like 8 percent of
the world's population or something like
that and that was such like an
emotionally devastating thing just eight
percent imagine at 50 percent ooh boy
maybe Carrie was actually in the
leftovers you played Proxima midnight
it's interesting to see her and you did
ask do we see part of the black order
again oh no they're fine well let us
know if you want answers probably no but
if you want us to get into what would
literally happen kind of like we've gone
into you know the Walking Dead we've had
videos about like what would actually
happen in that scenario what would
actually happen if we lost half of our
population that's a fun video when a lot
of planes crashed yeah yes so one kind
helicopter but they're all well let us
know down below in the comments with
what your theories are for which
characters you want to see come back in
different ways that they could bring
them back in a way that would feel
hopefully narrative ly satisfying bruh
now let's move on to this week's a
trivia question
[Music]
I believe infinity war-related this is a
new graphic okay so about to Devon oh
yeah hi Devon the question is in
Avengers infinity war III the blacksmith
dwarf of nineveh Lear is played by peter
dinklage tyrion lanister from Game of
Thrones what lined as III say to
reference a game of Thrones okay all of
our answers are in the bucket later
we'll reveal our answer to this trivia
question
the closest answer is decided by our
judges will do our sign-off good-byes at
the end of the video meanwhile the loser
will have to cleverly riff on our in
other news headlines but let us move on
okay guys quick news update here about a
Star Wars Episode nine because it is May
the 4th and it's Star Wars day Finn
actor John boyega teased that there
might be a time jump between the last
Jedi in the start of the third part of
the trilogy saying quote I can't wait to
start shooting the next and final leg of
the franchise the first step is growing
out my hair so you can wait for the
trailer to see why meanwhile reports
said that episode 9 is also casting a
new female character to fight alongside
Rey currently named Cairo or karo the
casting notice is looking for a quote
captivating naturalness and ease to her
manner as someone who's a leader in a
problem-solver smart with a great sense
of humor and a strong will all of this
comes to her effortlessly a word that
takes a great deal of effort for me to
say yeah just vary in tradition of Mary
Sue my one takeaway from the new Star
Wars movies is they don't have enough
character like don't worry twice as many
characters okay yeah it's something this
could be one of the Rays in the mirror
scene just popping out of the mirror
from last Jedi will see some interesting
news there I'm sure we'll get more shout
out to every girl Miami named Carol then
maybe your name that may just be like a
fake name that they use in the cat they
tend to do that with casting notices
like here's like insert name here like I
believe Keira was the name of a
of djenne or so or array I think in the
original like queue you I don't know you
I you are a watched our video for that
speaking of Star Wars news earlier this
week we saw release of a featurette for
solo a Star Wars story it had a ton of
new footage shots of Han as a
stormtrooper in training traumatized in
a swampy battle another one where he's
thrown in front of a big nasty war a
monster and then he there's a bit where
he hears Chewbacca roar his original
Wookiee name and he just responds out
you're gonna need a nickname because I'm
not gonna say that every time now
director Ron Howard is giving this movie
the hard sell as the rite of passage
origin story that we've always wanted to
see from one of the most exciting names
in the Star Wars universe meanwhile in
another interview Alden Ehrenreich spoke
about Ron Howard taking over director
duties from previous directors Phil Lord
and Chris Miller he said that the rumors
were bolt that the cast and crew
applauded at the news of their firing
that was something that was a party for
Dan Ehrenreich the transition was
actually a lot smoother and that's
largely thanks to Ron Howard's directing
expertise and his experience now solo
drops on May 25th and to me guys it's a
pretty surprising to see how low
excitement seems to be at least right
now for the movie a few years ago Star
Wars seemed like the hottest franchise
in Hollywood with Marvel as the number 2
but now it seems like those positions
have been flipped now this could just be
a product of the negative press around
solostar war story or like Marvel's
having its biggest movie ever in this
franchise
maybe Marvel's do in a slightly better
job with things like casting and
delivering the payoff that fans wanted
arguably I'm curious to know what you
guys thought sorry's we turned towards
we pivot towards solo star wars stories
the biggest thing on our radar what do
you think Marvel has done differently
with its properties and the star wars
team has this this is a fair argument be
clear we're not discussing because who
cares about like which one's better like
that's not really the discussion it's
like everything's great right now we're
living in the best lives ever had it's
it's why are we seeing more cultural
excitement for the Marvel Universe and
Star Wars universe and anecdotally I'll
just also point out our very recent solo
trailer breakdown didn't do so hot
plus if you don't even know it to exist
it you can check out the news on that
one and that kind of inspired a little
bit of scum
interesting well I mean it is more up
everyone's watch Star Wars for the most
part but if you haven't it's not fun to
be that person it's not fun to be the
person that didn't watch Star Wars when
you grew up I saw it I saw the prequels
and as a kid I enjoyed those more than
the original ones because they were
brighter and cooler and I didn't we got
lightsaber battles instead of just slow
Vader and obi-wan Kenobi just hitting
and then he dies and sorry then just
explaining that Marvel's more
approachable right now and there's more
people going to the theaters than ever
and it you feel like you're in on
something really special as they're
building up to this instead of just a
solid trilogy and having 30 years of
history prior to that but they're like
no there's novels you got to read and
there's comics and there's video games
you got to play and they're gonna pull
from all this and it's gonna build up to
this massive universe but it feels like
you're halfway through the journey
already with Marvel it was like we see
the start was 10 years ago and we built
up to this and it's yeah there's 20
movies and that's a lot but that's still
not a lot compared to how much Star Wars
memorabilia and just literature that's
out there right like not to be ages but
you does 10 years that you just picked
out or the people that watch things
right 1835 year olds are the ones that
go see things so people that were eight
years old to 25 years old were there for
like the beginning the 14 of the Marvel
Universe and day until being 35 like no
one's gonna lose interest in the Marvel
Universe
how old are the most that 18 35 year old
group that was out one Star Wars started
now because I think I think the Star
Wars franchise kind of overcorrected
from the prequels and kind of
misunderstood the the things people
didn't respond to with that one because
I don't think especially when you read a
ton of think pieces about all these
movies
I don't think general people are very
good about articulating why they don't
like something and so they just like
here's the thing everything you loved
about Star Wars again and here so
episode 7 comes out and it's like here's
the thing you love about Star Wars and
now here's rogue one you remember the
stuff you love about Star Wars x-wings
and Death Star's well here it is and now
episode eight comes out guess what more
x-wings and Tie Fighters and
stormtroopers and no mori Solo goes back
in time so you get to see young Han Solo
who's not your Harrison four with Tie
Fighters and a Millennium Falcon it's
like it's the same I feel like they've
been advertised
same movie for the past like four years
yeah I mean I think totally - there's
there's kind of a difference between if
you look at the Star Wars brand and the
Marvel brand the Marvel brand feels like
a restaurant with a very limited menu
like there's like eight things you know
like you know what you're getting when
you go there with Star Wars it's like a
big menu that has like lots of different
things like oh I'm not really into
seafood but they do seafood really well
with Marvel you've had ten years of
basically Kevin Feige vision he's been
telling this one story and he's had
little like he said directors who kind
of take over this one chapter of it but
it's basically Phibes vision Feige story
and the studio's given him creative
freedom to basically do that whereas
Star Wars it's more of a team there's a
lot of different voices coming needed
like JJ's force awakens is very
different from Ryan Johnson's the last
Jedi Kathleen Kennedy and George Lucas
are like creative consultants but they
don't have the control to create a
control over what these stories are the
same way Kevin Feige does at Marvel so
it's I can see why right now everyone
who loves pizza I think they have like
the best possible pizza they're gonna
get whereas like when last Jedi came out
there was maybe 30% of the fans there
was like this isn't the Star Wars yeah
for me and not even to underestimate
Kevin Feige at like sure he's amazing as
this storytellers architect of this
universe but also as like a business man
with the creative force to understand
where to put what stories right if you
are you know just in it for the action
or ever like the movies and the fun
stuff the thor ragnarok of it right but
if you're into it for like a little bit
more of like the drama it's like alright
that sounds like a character piece that
we should put on Netflix that we should
kind of like let breathe a little bit
and then like oh well you want like some
hip Punk's or whatever it's like okay
well we'll put you on Hulu cos kids are
the only people on Hulu and then you're
super nerdy while the details will you
solve the comics like everything is kind
of in its correct place meanwhile Star
Wars just kind of like everything's
gonna be a movie like everything major
is gonna be a movie and I don't care
what you like about it
they're prequels like the first one at
least it's like do you like palace
intrigue it's like no well it's the
movie movie of all time could you
imagine if if the
those parts the politics of the
situation of the overtaking and
formation of the Empire if that had been
a game of Thrones ask HBO series and
it's like actually like there's power
dynamics in stuff it could have maybe
been this thing where like the universe
was filling out in this way that was
satisfying instead it became straight-up
I hate to say this cuz it because what
we all are but it actually became like
nerdy to nerds to to like Star Wars
anymore to that extent because like I
mean I don't love every detail about
Star Wars universe and you're making me
have to go stand in line for a week for
these details I don't care so much about
that's why my sister did not let me
decorate my room in Darth Maul's cool I
thought so too and she's literally as I
was ordering from Home Shopping
Network she said wait think is this cool
is the one thing that comes out of those
prequels like murder earth was cool
holds up I mean look at you now you've
designed your whole that's it I am
actually I I feel like I should have be
very cynical about solo because I felt
that way since it was announced like why
are you even bothering
the most recent trailer looks really
cool like I almost wish it was its own
sci-fi thing and I didn't have to worry
about the Star Wars baggage that comes
with it I just wish it was its own
little sci-fi heist action movie I think
we're all gonna like I think we're all
gonna like it a lot more than I think
we've expected to like it I think once
it comes out or gonna be like you know
what no Ron Howard pulled some really
enjoyable like I don't think I'm gonna
there might be elements from like I'm
not feeling this like one Howard
narration over he's doing a Morgan
Freeman the narration Howard yeah but no
like I mean you brought up I think my
favorite point is just that they're
there as soon as you hit Avengers there
was a story and then moving on even
though it's like 20 plus movies after
that we had an idea of where it's going
and for me looking at Star Wars even
though people will disagree in million
different ways it felt like the story
was done in three movies and then after
that it's like let's explore but I'm
like why do I
to invest myself in this at least marvel
there is there is a payoff that was
coming
so is this time trying to course-correct
now by adding more characters and being
like oh we done messed up and we have
four maybe six really interesting
characters from our original trilogy and
Marvel's like welcome meet my friends
like they can't give enough movies out
how many characters they have that are
interesting so is this why there maybe
try we're demanding more movies for more
carrot like we want x-men to come over
because we want to see their take on it
in Fantastic Four because we want to see
their take on it we want defenders to
come in the movies because we want to
see what they're all like together I
what was it lobster man scissors fingers
did you know what the Denny's they
released a bunch of he's not in this
scene he's in another scene later on but
he's just a giant Lobster and it's like
I don't I don't I'm gonna buy the toy
but I don't want to know more about you
yes someone is I mean ultimately this
these are all properties owned by Disney
right so it's just saying like which it
Disney's kids it's interesting I think
going back to what you guys are saying I
think this is even more specifically a
problem for the most recent trilogy
because you had JJ come in with his
vision and then Ryan was like no forget
that vision I got this vision and he
added characters that he wanted to do
since he was a kid and now JJ was coming
back as I had more character so I wanted
to do when I was a kid watching these
movies and so it doesn't feel like it
feels like none of it really it would
have been better if you had one team
right that like this is it this is the
trilogy this is what we're building to
so it didn't feel like a big course
corrects every time a new person came in
yeah I enjoyed last Jedi but it does
feel like fanfic it feels like
fanfiction II feel like what if Luke was
angry all the time and like he drank
milk out of this seal thing yeah let us
know what you think about this in the
comments below yeah this is you know
there's no one right answer to this and
we were curious your thoughts is it
something like do you want a bit more
like diversity of the kinds of stories
are gonna tell like here or do you want
to be like just sat down to be like this
is what the story is now go to bed and
rest easy and we'll kill off half the
characters you love but yeah way I'm
gonna comment slow we're really curious
what you guys think but for now let's
quickly move on to another update big
news this week DC and Warner Brothers
upcoming streaming service announced a
live-action Swamp Thing series produced
by Aquaman director James Wan Swamp
Thing is a doctor
alik Holland who gets transformed into a
monstrous magically empowered swamp
creature there's a hole and more
mythology it's very interesting you
should you should read more on it now
the series is rumored to take on the
point of view of swamp things love
interest abbey arcane and I don't have
like a general horror tone to it it's
one of the writers is a guy who wrote it
and it'll join other series on this DC
streaming service Titans Young Justice
in an animated Harley Quinn series okay
everyone Avengers infinity war ended
with a real shocker and one last spoiler
warning guys you really have had plenty
of time to see it they ass actually uses
the Infinity Gauntlet to snap away half
the universe and to break the hearts of
everyone who loves spider-man and Black
Panther and the one guy who's really
Anna mantis but if you were watching
closely right after Danice returns from
Soul world and zips away from Thor the
post snap Infinity Gauntlet looks
cracked and smoky and overcooked now
there's some debate over whether or not
you could see Tanis wearing the gauntlet
later
but leave in the final shot movie but
you if you were looking more closely you
can kind of see thinnest his armor
hanging up off to the side so he does
have some of the stuff it's a nod to the
Infinity Gauntlet comics worthiness
retires on a farm and hangs up his armor
on a scarecrow it's kind of fun but that
this smokey shot brings up a question is
the Infinity Gauntlet broken now of
course Stannis could still open up a
portal a portal and escape from Thor
which required the space stone but can
he use the Infinity stones in
combination ever again it mess up his
arm pretty bad it looked like even like
above it yeah you point out something
interesting there cuz when you look at
the movie it's like why are we spending
so much time on Thor getting another
hammer like yeah that feels like a real
like just something we could've like
streamlined as entertaining as it is
because I like Thor with rocket and
Groot
but maybe we find out that the people
that built the hammer also built the
gauntlet so maybe the stones are fine
but we need another mechanism which
actually looked like there was one
sitting there another mechanism to use
it maybe that's why they went through
the trouble of introducing it because
it'll matter in the next movie yeah yeah
I think I'm not sure on this but I feel
like the thing that we see there is the
mold yeah for the gauntlet that they do
make but I do think that also means like
we could make an
but I think Eric's point is the one that
I'm abiding by right now they can't
right now in its current state it can't
do it again
yeah yeah that's that maybe one time can
be used but the idea of putting the
power stone behind the you know like the
the I guess the soul stone maybe it's
one that's like wiping the universal
Road but the thing that is enhancing the
other ones
that's probably what broke it and
overloaded it yeah yeah yeah the stones
can't be used in tandem like we saw in
some of the battles like he's using both
the reality stone and the space stone at
the same time or he'll use the space
stone to like phase shift Hulk into a
mountain and and the power stone to like
punch Captain America out of the way he
can't do these things at the same time
at least anymore and arguably the stones
could be separated now do you read it
clean and I would argue that I do think
it's got to be relevant that we saw it
so damaged because from a writing
perspective that's a fascinating
situation to put yourselves in as the
Russo brothers another brother team the
Coen brothers famously had this rule
where they would write a situation for
their characters that was so difficult
to figure out how they're gonna solve
this that if they could as the writers
come up with a solution within two weeks
they were like well then this isn't hard
enough oh well make it even worse on
their characters so I feel like the idea
that we're all like oh well you could
just get the gauntlet off his arm and do
it they're like okay so let's break the
gauntlet like let's give ourselves as
many problems with me and just so that
in this year that we have of waiting
none of us are like I know how he does
it you know what you know it's 100 cent
gonna be there it's gonna be their
version yeah it's gonna be the they're
gonna introduce a version of the
infinity watch like how many Avengers
are left from the original team six yeah
each one gets a stone they have to use
it in tandem to undo the things so yeah
so you see they they push the beams
together and then finally
sucked into the little beam any pops so
that might not be it but it wouldn't
surprise me if this is the mechanism
that they used to introduce something
close to infinity watch and it would be
these characters because a lot of them
and they're not going to keep paying
robert downey jr the money they're
paying yeah you can you just can you
explain what so in the comics because
the Infinity stones are so dangerous
when brought together the either divided
up against amongst a group of cosmic
individuals most of which we haven't
seen Drax and Gamora in their Adam
warlock as a part of it you might have
heard about him in talks with guardians
and then moon dragon which is a version
of Drax is daughter Oh which is it's
more if you go into like sixties
seventies cosmic Marvel it's super
confusing actually adapt that to another
team not really but that people want is
Illuminati because they did the same
thing yeah taste of Illuminati and some
conversations in this of like I was like
oh I love these potential conversations
yeah in in one of the Avengers teams
because there's they always like revamp
at every couple months but you find out
that Black Bolt Professor X Doctor
Strange iron man and a couple other like
big leaders for different teams and
Marvel hit Infinity stones in different
places but mostly on earth which was not
a great idea in that story but it does
make it very interesting so you could
get like a version
yeah that way now I make more sense with
the characters we've been to introduce
to yeah yeah so in that scenario would
be what black panther Tony Stark Doctor
Strange after they've used it yeah if
theoretically they fix everything
yeah although I do think I would I would
be shocked if we come out of this movie
with both Iron Man and cap fine I think
Canada I think caps done both like have
such good reasons to leave at this point
jr. seems like he likes it more but I
think what's good to point out it's not
only is the Infinity Gauntlet looking
fried and broken meaning that they can't
do another snap it means to me that this
can't be reversed that simply it's not
like this is but if this was a light
switch it couldn't be flipped back off
you know so I think it is critical not
like oh and the threat is over but like
the way to fix the threat or reverse the
threat is no longer an option it's gonna
take at least three hours to figure out
yeah and like 20 maybe more is that the
ant-man and Captain Marvel probably well
let us know what your theories about the
status of the Infinity Gauntlet are in
the comments below and and what
different implications it being possibly
broken are you know it's time to move on
to our new rock stars news you guys
sweetie this question we're gonna fire
them at each other and we have to answer
these questions as quickly without
hesitation as possible are we ready away
we go it's upside-down Sam at Singler
Ashley wants to know what non Marvel
movie are you looking forward to Aquaman
oh yes Ben and Jerry's would make you
guys ice cream what would your flavor be
all of us will you but yeah we should
only greasy it's a cool in a hat
scoop and DJ's there I got it I got the
hand often about yourself that if the
word that comes to mind when I think of
us food which is often
DJ at glum underscore Li 28 wants to
know what game do you want to turn into
a movie if it isn't one already oh man I
was just talking to some about this the
other day my my knee-jerk reaction is to
say The Witcher but honestly I'd rather
see that as a series because it just
lends itself to like a serialize or even
like a case of the monster of the week
type situation really well what's
another you know what I just recently
played the Uncharted games and I think
if you if you did it right you run the
risk up because it's already kind of
like a redo of Indiana Jones so it if
you do it wrong it looks like a redo of
a redo but if you did it right could be
really cool especially the second game I
mean those games are movies you get the
play in are a lot longer but hey if you
want a shorter one that you don't get to
play everybody I'm picking at Alex
Basie's question for you
name one character that you think should
have been killed infinity war and wasn't
and one character that you think should
not have been killed mmm
I would do the nebula Groot trade if you
can't keep some from the Guardians I
think I mean I will see you never
probably has an important reason to stay
alive but gruta it's gonna be a bummer
if I you know I could always use more
crude in the movie so your argument to
kill now I will say I think that's
really good I agree that reason I will
say that in the Infinity Gauntlet comic
those questions and keeping out for
tweets next week thank you all next up
let's take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel the next week guys it's gonna be
a lot more infinity war stuff we're
gonna answer a lot more questions that
you guys have had specifically about the
timeline how the timeline has is
different the gauntlet windows am in the
wants to take place we're gonna look at
all the evidence and pieces it together
for you we're talking about Red Skull
we're talk about thinness is motivation
the Black Panther blu-ray came out we
want to
talk about that a lot more we're gonna
look at roads we've got some deleted
scene oh yeah a lot of interesting stuff
phase four how Avenue where has updated
phase four the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and then yeah Deadpool it's coming out
in a couple weeks and solo after that so
keep an eye out for all types of videos
on that stuff but for now it comes time
for our 15-second shout out each of us
has 15 seconds to shout out plug or
ramble about anything we want if you go
for 15 seconds it's probably okay but
Sam why don't you start well DJ and I
and a couple of our friends are doing a
live show in LA if you go to my
Instagram or only stupid answers
Instagram you probably find a link to
buying tickets it's at the open space
cafe Steve Zaragoza Mike Falzone Maude
Garrett we're gonna be doing a bunch of
different podcasts like a little
showcase it's gonna be a blast or gonna
be exclusive stuff there also if you're
part of the only stupid answers patreon
you can probably get a live stream
version of it and a VOD version of that
so check that out
Tuesday May 8th at 8 p.m. nice for my 15
seconds I've been watching season 2 of
The Handmaid's Tale I love that show I
mean it's it's like good terrifying
science fiction that is looking less and
less fictional if you're following
current events but you know it's just
it's supremely well acted by Elizabeth
moss and it's it was one my favorite
shows season one last year and season
two it's like going deeper and deeper
into this terrifying world so yeah oh
yeah yeah my 15 seconds I'll give most
of it to DJ so you can talk about this
thing I'll just say tale of tales on
Netflix it's like if the Brothers Grimm
they stayed as creepy as those fairy
tales should have been check it out
that's awesome
so for me if you go to chaos theory
comic dot-com I have AI vol 2 of my
comic book cast theories Ami's based
dinosaurs
it delivers exactly what's in the title
you got zombies fightin dinosaurs a
group of survivors that this desperately
don't want to be eaten by either you
might even have aliens this was just a
big I might he said my listen I wanted
to do everything I want to do something
as comic book II as I could possibly do
like just fit every big idea ever had
each it's five issues in one volume each
issue could be its own standalone
blockbuster I shove as many ideas as I
could in there for new rockstars
listeners if you go to chaos theory
comic calm and you pick up a rewards
here $25 or more
and you can go there's a little comment
section on kicks are you going there you
said hey I'm from new rock stars I will
match that up with your rewards here
that you chose and give you a bonus
reward which is a postcard map of the
United States in this world and change
yeah it's called the undead states of
america and things aren't going so hot
for everybody there's a lot there's a
lot of story details that I wasn't able
to fit into the comic that will be on
the back side of that postcard and
you'll get a good idea of what is going
on in the world there with that so if
you go to Casa I'm gonna come pick a
rewards here $25 or up and you say hey
I'm from new rock stars that will go in
there for you I wouldn't feel bad about
the head at all thanks DJ and yeah
definitely jump on that everybody we're
gonna return to our trivia question I
got wrong
[Music]
everyone got a different took me some so
just to remind everyone what the
question was the question was in
Avengers infinity war III the blacksmith
dwarf of nineveh is played by peter
dinklage tyrion lanister from Kamath
rhodes what line does each tree say to
reference Game of Thrones let's go down
the line and see what everyone said okay
so this is Philip he said there is
incest in these in this universe - Sam
said you get to live but your hands are
mine I feel like that would be in yeah
well DJ said yeah that's what dying
means which I feel like that happened
season 5 who cares
he's like only if I die no I guess cut
and I think that's what the guy said
when he got turned into a water of
squish watermelon he said that DJ what's
the answer
oh it's it's hold the door oh it's all
the door somebody does he say hold the
door one of these is definitely closer
than the yeah yeah
so who's closest judges there's
interests in this universe too which is
a fact hold the Thor that's the closest
all right the yeah that's what dying
means and then you get to live but your
hands are mine who's the first dying the
word dying is used in quema France I
don't know I just thought that was that
line that made sense for Game of Thrones
yeah that's definitely in the infinity
war yes
and I know there dance in Game of
Thrones
I don't worry don't worry everybody
there's okay well I have gotten closest
and then Philip it sounds like is our
farthest away so just a reminder I'll do
our good-byes first we're gonna quickly
run through our in other news headlines
so we didn't have time for let's have a
DJ read each of the headlines yeah if
you can lean in there on the screen here
do you just gonna read the headline is
set it up Philips gonna have to make a
joke at the end of each headline to
cleverly riff on it ready all right here
we go
our first headline coming up Ryan
Reynolds revealed that he has never seen
his own Green Lantern movie I which is
means that Ryan Reynolds is that much
better off bideo was released of Mark
Ruffalo accidentally spoiling the ending
of infinity war in an interview last
summer I so turn turns out The Hulk is
on his way
Oh God to Holland because he's acting
like Tom Holland oh yeah
you'll find the Han Solo director Ron
Howard narrated a parody video of the
Star Wars saga in the style of Arrested
Development I and what he didn't narrate
was the allegations against Jeffrey
Tambor black panthers deleted scenes
include a clip of Maccabi played by
Daniel Cole Ouya arguing with a co a
which test audiences suggested needed to
be cut because Cola yeas bad accent was
distracting and then lastly comedian Ben
Schwartz revealed that in addition to
voicing bb-8 in the force awakens he
also played one of the stormtroopers
because of course he did I its name is
John Ralph oh yeah
my god you did good he did and he did a
pretty good job why do you guys watch
this well thank you for watching this
week's episode of new rockstars news
guys I thank our host Sam bachelor at
Sam bachelor on Twitter
Phillip Molina at fimo and DJ Wooldridge
a DJ talks trash and yeah good make sure
to check out his is what's the name of
the theory congress.com
yeah and comment with your thoughts down
below guys tweet us at new rock stars
like this video share around and
subscribing to rock stars with deep
dives on all the stuff you love mostly
it's just been I'm gonna be worth stuff
this week but you know what other things
will grab our attention and and time
well until then see you next week
everybody in fact new pants and I've
been walking around all day with this
sticker all the way down the back of my
leg wait for us to cut that out cuz you
said it too soon uh-huh stars stars